we begin with this for the second time
in less than a week a small jet has
crashed at an airport in flames and
miraculously everybody on board survived
again the twin-engine Cessna jet ran off
the runway yesterday at Auroville
Municipal Airport that's north of
Sacramento
authorities say the plane had problems
during takeoff the NTSB and FAA are
investigating Kris Van Cleave shows us
how remarkably everyone on the plane
survived flames poured from the
twin-engine Cessna Citation moments
after the jet skidded off in Northern
California runway Wednesday the plane
was headed from Orville to Portland
Oregon we don't know why but the pilots
aborted takeoff Zeke Higgins witnessed
what happened next I ended up going
inside in the pro shop telling the guys
about it I walked back out and on sudden
I see an explosion over there and the
planes gone eight passengers and two
pilots were on board everybody escaped
without injury the plane had 400 gallons
of jet fuel on board the burning
aircraft sparked a grass fire if you'd
have seen you know the enormous ball of
fire and smoke it's they're very very
lucky people the Cessna was a charter
operated by Delta private jets in a
statement the company said in part while
the cause of the incident is currently
under investigation we are providing
support to customers involved through
RIA Commendation and other resources
this is the second crash involving a
Cessna Citation jet in less than a week
okay everybody all right NASCAR legend
Dale Earnhardt jr. his wife and daughter
were landing in Tennessee last Thursday
when their plane crashed and caught fire
Earnhardt and family managed to escape
that crash alive
the Earnhardt crash involved a newer
model of the Cessna Citation than the
one that went off the runway yesterday
the accidents are different but as the
NTSB investigates they're certainly
going to be looking for any
commonalities that may have contributed
to the two fires we expect an update on
the Earnhardt crash in the coming days
Dale Earnhardt jr. says he'll be
attending an auto race this weekend
Tony glad everyone is okay Chris thank
you very much